Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim. Ähm.
Helau. Hm.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zwo vier drei zweihundertdreiundvierzig vom zwölften Februar zweitausendachtzehn direkt aus dem spaßbefreiten Berlin. Ja.
Ja hier ist hier.
Wir sind uns ja, wir sind ja immer sehr stolz darauf.
Dass das hier jeden Tag so aussieht wie Rosenmontag woanders.
Ja, nee, das einfach uns das äh also vielleicht ist diese Ignoranz ja auch schlecht und vielleicht fehlt uns ja auch was in unserem Leben.
Aber es fühlt sich nicht so an. Ich habe mir mal irgendwie von Mädel auf einer Party.
Ich fragte sie so, na ja so Karneval und so und was.
Was ist was? Das schaut mich ganz an und meinte, na, da steht das Pferd auf dem Flur.
Ja, das ist eines der Lieder, die man da singt.
Das ist mir okay, alles klar.
Ich frage dich jetzt nicht, warum Union Berlin, dann wirst du auch irgendwie ein Brauchtum.
Und nur in Berlin war's.
Genau, die Frage, die Antwort kriegst ja auch. Wenn du fragst, warum Karneval.
Ich könnte das schon äh ausführlicher darlegen, aber das,
jetzt hier nicht äh hin.
Ähm wir.
Wir haben ja einen Auftrag.
Wir haben einen Bildungsauftrag, den wir natürlich auch am Rosenmontag nachkommen.
Wir jecken.
Das einzige einzige, was mich wirklich interessiert ist, wie die jetzt eigentlich mit dieser SPD-Dramatik klarkommen. Die haben.
Doch auch alles nur vom Karneval. Das ist doch auch alles nur Karneval, was die SPD da gerade macht.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, es zerhaut nicht, die haben wahrscheinlich schon drei von ihren komischen Umzugswagen, die ihren Themenwagen schon abgefackelt und komplett neu gebaut und dann zwei Tage später, scheiße. Doch schon wieder anders.
Auf jeden Fall alle Kamelle verballern inzwischen.
Was er hat. Was soll man denn dazu noch sagen? Ich meine, man fasst sich einfach so kollektiv so dermaßen an Kopf die ganze Zeit.
Ich finde das äh ich glaube bei Spiegel Online gab's einen schönen Artikel, der also sagte so, das ist jetzt,
Also das ist jetzt nur noch tragisch im Sinne von,
Tragödie, also eben so, die merkt meine eine Tranködie. Ähm hier haben wir sie, äh das ist äh nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr nachzuvollziehen.
Nicht nur nachvollziehbar, ne.
Ja.
Einzige Person, die noch durchblickt ist, Sigmar Gabriels, fünfjährige Tochter.
Von.
Habe ich gerade gehört von von Martin Schulz, Schwester jetzt aber auch schon wieder zurechtgewiesen wurde.
Auf WhatsApp oder Instagram.
Aus der, die ist aus der WhatsApp-Gruppe der fünf B geflogen.
Oh man, geht heiß her. Social Media Wald.
Ja, also. Ich bin, also das werden wir auch hier tatsächlich nicht großartig. Ich hab schon ernsthaft überlegt, ob wir uns überhaupt durch diesen ganzen Koalitionsvertrag lesen müssen.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sich.
Weil du ja nicht weißt, was die als nächstes von von ihrem Karnevalswagen.
Weißt du, du weißt ja noch nicht mal, ob der überhaupt zustande kommt jetzt.
Ja. Vierundzwanzigtausend neue Mitglieder, die SPD läuft, würde ich sagen. Also die Kasse klingelt.
Ich freue mich, was sie was sie was sie da wollen. Also ich mein.
Ja die wollen die, die sind, die treten doch ein auf äh äh Zuruf von Kevin Kühnert, dem Juso-Vorsitzenden, der sagt, äh tretet ein und stimmt gegen die GroKo beide Mitglieder.
Oder auf Zuruf von Herrn Spahn, der sagt, irgendwie tretet ein und stimmt dafür ab.
Also ich was wird tatsächlich an diesem an dieser Kirmes da Sorgen macht ist.
Ähm bei allem, bei aller Unzufriedenheit mit der mit dem politischen Entscheidungen, die wir hier ähm jede Woche beklagen, müssen wir doch glaube ich eins anerkennen,
dieses Land war immer recht stabil,
Das merkt man auch daran, dass sich eigentlich nichts geändert hat. Also wir sind sehr stabil und vorhersehbar immer in die gleiche Richtung marschiert. Mehr Überwachung, weniger Freiheit, weniger Netzneutralität.
Da weiß man, was man hat.
Alles, alles garantiert schlechter und wenn man das abgewehrt hat, kommt es nächstes Jahr wieder. So, da weiß man, so das ist Stabilität. Und das ist für Menschen in dem Land.
Hat es auch ein Vorteil.
Kontrolliert kontrollierte Sicherheitsinflation ist das sozusagen.
Genau, kontrollierte Sicherheit, man weiß einfach, nächstes Jahr kommen die wieder mit der Vorratsdatenspeicher.
Eins Komma acht Prozent mehr Versicherheitsgesetzverschärfung. Aber es hält sich halt noch im Rahmen.
Nächstes Jahr kommen die wieder mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und ütten Staatsreaner. Und äh so das war Verlässlichkeit, ja, Deutschland, verlässlicher Pater, Partner für,
Die Hersteller von der Software und Hardware, die man dafür braucht. Ähm.
Inzwischen drohen uns hier oder wir blicken natürlich auch auf die Länder so Spanien, Italien äh Großbritannien, USA, das kann uns nicht passieren, ja? Und jetzt sitzen wir hier und haben irgendwie innerhalb von,
Am Karnevalswochenende, ja? Zwei Clowns zerlegen den kompletten Politikbetrieb nachhaltig.
Inner im Prinzip übern Kölsch. Ja, also das ist Karneval Timo. Du wolltest dich ja mal er.
Das ist Karneval. Du wolltest das ja mal. Ich komme der Sache langsam näher, ja. Ist in Wirselinder eigentlich ist das auch so eine Karnevalshochsp.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es tatsächlich nicht.
Ja, der Siggi, der kommt doch irgendwie aus, aus, aus Goslar, das ist doch irgendwie auch weitgehend Spaß befreit. Wobei im Harz bin ich mir da schon ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr so sicher.
Ich weiß das nicht, ich habe da also ähm weiß ich tatsächlich nicht, kann ich dir nicht genau sagen, verfolge ich nicht.
Komm, wir machen mal hier äh Feedback und dann gucken wir uns mal an, was die, dann lesen wir mal die Büttenrede äh vom die Blütenrede vom Koalitions äh Vertrag.
Mach das ganz kirre, dass oben eine falsche Sendungsnummer steht auf dem Pad, kannst du das mal eben ändern.
Das mache ich doch glatt. Die CDU.
Nein, guck mal, das ist die Sendung, ha, das ist die Sendung, auf die das sich bezieht. Das ist nämlich die Sendung zweihunderteinundvierzig. Da haben wir ähm.
Statt aber zweihundertvierzehn.
Ja du hast das falsch gemacht, nicht ich.
Ach so, ich war's jetzt wieder.
Der
Feedback zu der, also die letzte Sendung war ja die mit Markus, wo wir sehr schönes Feedback zu hatten, aber auch davor hatten wir die Sendung zweihunderteinundvierzig, da hatten wir auch noch Feedback zu, was ich auch nochmal kurz verlesen möchte. Und zwar haben wir über diese Strafa Geschichte
quatscht mit den Militärbasen und das ich sagte auf Twitter meinten einige der Gärbis GPS-Gemmer, da korrigiert Patrick
Man kann im Strafer Popie Profil hin Locations anlegen,
wo um einen einstellbaren Umkreis um eine bestimmte Koordinate herum der eigene Track nicht angezeigt wird,
Und das ist wohl aufgekommen, nachdem bei verschiedenen Nutzern im Keller eingestiegen wurde und die hochwertigen Fahrräder verschwunden sind. Also mit anderen Worten du guckst auf Strafer.
Läuften der immer.
Hier zügig die Runde,
oder du setzt dich schön an, was weiß ich im Berliner Mauerweg hin, wo die Inlinefahrer und die Rennradfahrer immer langschießen und sagst oh schickes Rätchen, ne? Und dann guckst du nachher, wer hat denn bei Straver um die Uhrzeit,
ordentliche Zeit geliefert und dann gehst du abends dahin mit der Zange und holst dir das Candy aus dem Keller. Äh danke.
Äh danke. Das ist wirklich echt so geil.
Also das ist natürlich.
Aber Linus, man hat nichts zu verbergen. Überhaupt nicht.
Nein, wir haben nichts zu verbergen. Hast du Angst, dass man dir was wegnimmt.
Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin jetzt nicht gerade aus der Aluhut-Fraktion, aber ich weiß nicht auch datenmäßig halbwegs zu benehmen, also,
So mit dem Posten auf so öffentlichen Plattformen von so Zeit und Wegachsen, da weiß ich schon wo ich mich zurückhalten muss. Oh man Leute echt.
Jonas Schönfelder, bekannt aus äh technischer Aufklärung ähm sagt kleine Korrektur zur Geschichte des AfD-Politikers, der ein Netzpolitik Org Artikel als seine Rede vorgetragen hat, das war im,
Vorpommerischen Landtag und nicht im Bundestag. Danke für den Hinweis,
hätten wir wissen müssen stand da auch, haben wir uns wohl in der Freude, dass äh äh im im Überschwang.
Haben uns das hochgejub.
Du hast das hochgejest. Aber das ähm das bemängelt auch quer sagte äh und sagt
besser von Netzpolitik abschreiben, als sich die Reden und Gesetzentwürfe von der Telekom Lobby diktieren lassen, wie es zum Beispiel irgendwelche EU-Digitalkommissare gemacht haben
was irgendein AfD-Hinterbänkler im MV Landtag sagt, ist völlig irrelevant, aber Hauptsache, man konnte wieder AfD-Bashing betreiben.
Ja, ist doch schön.
Nun ähm wenn äh
die Digitalkommissare sowas machen, dann behandeln wir das hier ja auch ausführlich und ich erinnere da an äh die Projekte Lobby Plug, die wir hier gewürdigt haben und äh die Arbeit, die wir auch sonst betreiben, um um solche Plagiate,
herauszufinden, aber es ist natürlich äh.
Wir haben einfach beides, Country und West.
Wir bashen AfD und EU-Digitalkommissare, weil wir haben genug Wut für alle.
Wut. Das ist jetzt wieder so ein hartes Wort. Ähm emotionale Beteiligung.
Nein, wir haben genug Kamelle. Hier haben wir heute.
Das reißt jetzt ein. Genau, wir betrubbeln die alle mit Kamille. Ich, ich kriege das noch hin.
Zu der zu der zweihunderteinundvierzig kommertiert Sandra.
Zweihundertzweiundvierzig, genau zu der Sendung mit Markus, über das besondere elektronische Arbeitspassfach. Kommentiert Sana. Vielen Dank, das war eine ganz großartige Sendung.
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, die in der Mitte aufgemacht werden muss. Frage frage ich mich immer, wer da eigentlich so ein Verständnisproblem hat. Worte haben eine Bedeutung, es würde ja auch niemand einen Direktflug mit umsteigen akzeptieren.
Den muss ich mir merken. Das ist ein seit wie vielen Jahren, ja.
Seit wie vielen Jahren.
Wie viele Gutachten habe ich jetzt irgendwie zu diesem Thema geschrieben, aber auf diese sehr schöne äh danke Sandra, das finde ich sehr schön. Ein Direktflug mit umsteigen. Äh.
Das versteht auch der Politiker von heute.
Ja, vor allem wisst ihr die, wie Scheiße umsteigen ist.
Genau. Euer eure Ende zu Ende äh äh Transport von Bonn nach Berlin führt jetzt einfach immer nochmal über Basel. Kann euch, ich kann nur, also es ist ja, ne, oder bei London oder.
Zweimal umsteigen kurz in Heavrow, umsteigen, ist doch kein.
Ist ja nichts. Da kann man auch noch schön shoppen gehen und so.
Und dann fand ich noch sehr student, der Kommentar ist äh von der ARD. Die zwei zweiundvierziger überzeugt mit einer üppigen Portion Light und Verzweiflung, dezent abgeschmeckt mit neumannschem Tränen
eine Note Weltschmerz. Sie gehört zum Besten, mit dem der Konissör schlechter Nachrichten. Sein Hörgauben kitzeln kann. Das fand ich sehr schön,
das ist einfach mal ein Lob, normalerweise versuchen wir ja nur vorzulesen, wenn das äh eine Ergänzung ist, aber das fand ich so schön formuliert, dass äh welche,
Dann habe ich als erstes Thema notiert was erlaube Schulz, das haben wir aber glaube ich jetzt schon irgendwie durch, oder?
Na ja wir können's ja mal vielleicht auch nochmal versuchen ein bisschen zu chronologisieren. Das das ist man man konnte ja irgendwie schon gar nicht mehr so richtig hinterher, ne? Es ist ja alles dann immer schon wieder anders als eben grad noch war,
Was ist eigentlich passiert? Also SPD wollte erst überhaupt nicht mehr in, also erst wollten sie den Kanzler stellen, den Gott. Den Gottkanzler.
Er sollte erst. Erst wollte der Schulz Kanzler werden.
Genau. Gab's, da gab's sowieso eine schöne äh Geschichte hier auf diesem äh Spiegelbassfit, da auf Bento,
ähm über den, über den Typen, der das mit diesem Schulzug äh angerollt hat, was am Anfang und dem Gottkanzler mehm und so weiter. Und er hat ihnen auch angeboten, dass dass irgendwie mit denen so durchziehen,
Und die haben dem einfach nur so einen Brief geschrieben mit einem ja äh Doncall Aspeku, ja wir kriegen das irgendwie auch schon alleine hin, vielen Dank.
So viel zum Thema moderne Partei. Also die haben sozusagen die Steinvorlage an der Stelle komplett einfach sausen lassen,
Und dann ging das ja auch gleich weiter, also diese geile Entscheidung,
in dieser Halbphase ausgerechnet den Schulz aus dem Wahlkampf in NRW rauszulassen, wo sie dann kolossal verloren haben. Wer kommt auf solche Ideen? Ich meine, wer denkt sich sowas aus? Und vor allem warum setzt sich dann,
der Schulz da auch nicht selber drüber hinweg, das ist mir die ganze Zeit so ein Rätsel, warum der so komplett nee, also der hatte alle Vorlagen, die man sich nur irgendwie wünschen kann.
Und ne,
Neue Eintritte und Pipapo. Ich meine, ich halte das alles nicht für gerechtfertigt, ehrlich gesagt aus Distanz, aber es war halt nun mal so und aus so einem Hype muss man auch was machen. Aber mit mit welcher Umtriebigkeit und mit mit welcher,
Das ist ein richtiger Parfümsritt des Niedermachens der eigenen Chancen.
Ja. Und dann und dann dann verliert er vorhersehbar die Wahl, ja?
Dann tönt er da noch groß rum, ja? Wir stehen äh wir sind Oppositionsführer und alle so hellau, hellau, wir sind Oppositionsführer und und stehen da und alle, jawohl, der Karnevalsprinz, Martin Schulz hat gesprochen
und dann kommt er irgendwie eine Woche später und sagt, ja äh vielleicht ähm vielleicht doch eine große Koalition, ja? Und,
Auch das von mir aus, ne? Konnte ja keiner wissen, dass Christian Lindner ähm,
Irgendwie kein ausgewachsener äh Erwachsener ist so, das war ja überhaupt nicht vorhersehbar, das wusste man ja gar nicht, dass das irgendwie,
Auch so ein Kirmestyp ist, ja? Ähm,
kommt so. War ja so und dann sagen sie, okay, Mist, wir haben uns da verschätzt, wir haben gehofft, wir konnten den ähm wir könnten dem Lindner hier den schwarzen Peter zuschanzen, hat nicht geklappt. Jetzt müssen wir doch eine GroKo wieder machen, ne? Und alle irgendwie so, oh hm,
OK? Da wäre lieber Martin Schulz der Moment gewesen.
Ja, ob's gerade noch ein schönes Foto.
Vor tollen Posen zu vollen Hosen. Siehste, Tim, jetzt werkst du langsam so den Karneval, kommt jetzt auch bei dir an, ne? Die feigen,
feige demokratische Partei. So dann kommt er dann da wäre der Moment gewesen wo der Schulz hätte sagen müssen jut,
Alles, was ich hier angekündigt habe, alles, was ich versprochen habe, ähm habe ich verkackt, ja? Jetzt ist der Moment, wo ich aufrecht,
Von dieser Bühne gehe zurück nach wo immer auch hin, aber mich von dieser Bühne verabschiede.
Damit wäre auch noch durchgekommen. Ja, Nahles hat ja dann noch die die flammende Rede gehalten. Hier und äh die die zeigen uns einen Vogel. Ja, das hat sie
grob hat sie grob erkannt so. Die Gefahr war also so das Risiko stand im Raum könnte man sagen so, ne?
Und dann machen sie da dann dann gehen die nachverhandeln,
kommen mit ihrem ersten Koalitionsvertrag, äh mit ihrem ersten Entwurf, der zurück, werden ausgelacht. Kommen mit einem besseren Koalitionsvertrag zurück, wo tatsächlich Jan, die kommen ja gleich noch zu. Einiges so, wo einige sagen, na ja okay, das könnte man unter Umständen echt so machen,
Und dann sagt der Schulz, ach ja und übrigens ähm ich werde Außenminister dann, habe ich mir gedacht, ne.
Ja vorher gesagt hab ich tritt auf gar keinen Fall in ein Kabinett Merkel ein.
Ja, weil weil ich wollte ja eigentlich Bundeskanzler werden und dann denkst du dir so, okay krass so, dass sie, dass der Gabriel da mitspielt.
Aber noch nicht mal Vizekanzler.
Eine Vizekanze am Ende nicht werden.
Genau, er wollte nicht Vizekanzler werden, aber er wollte Außenminister werden.
Das war das eine, die eine Sache, die in Garien's Leben Spaß gemacht hat, die dir die dem Spaß gemacht hat, die der hingekriegt hat und wo die Leute sagten, der Taste so gut gemacht, Gabriel ist ja einer der beliebtesten Politiker in Deutschland gerade, ne.
Außenminister sind immer die beliebtesten Politiker in Deutschland.
Richtig, deswegen wollte der Gabriel das wahrscheinlich auch weitermachen und wahrscheinlich wollte der Schulz, dass deswegen auch machen. Na ja, hat er aber irgendwie mit dem Gabriel nicht drüber gesprochen. Nächsten Tag sagt der Gabriel.
Ich denke, der hat sogar mit dem Gabriel drüber gesprochen, dass genau das nicht passiert, dass der Gabriel nämlich irgendwie seinen Platz behält und dementsprechend ist man dann.
Deswegen war der, deswegen war der Schulz, der überhaupt Kanzlerkandidat, weil er sich mit dem Parteivorsitzenden damals noch Gabriel darau.
Du bist Kandidat, du bist Vollstar, ich will nur Außenminister machen, lass mich in Frieden mit deinem Scheiß, irgendwie, wenn ihr gewinnt, dann bleibe ich Außenminister und ansonsten haben wir halt beide Pech gehabt. Das war der Deal.
Adel, ja, kann man so kann man so,
kann man so machen. Nur weil Schulz hat halt irgendwie alle anderen Spielzeuge kaputt gemacht
und guckte sich dann jetzt wie in dem in guckte sich um so, ne? Der Karnevalsabend, der Rosenmontag neigte sich dem Ende zu und er sagte so was noch Fresse,
Außenminister, so.
Hat doch der Siggi auch so schön gemacht. Das da flüchtet man doch hin, wenn man nicht hörvorsitzender sein will.
Schnappt er das die Siggi weg so? Und dann denkst du dir na gut? Dann gibt der Sigmar Gabriel ein verschnupftes Interview,
und sagt, ja hier Wort gilt nix mehr und so weiter, bin ich ein bisschen enttäuscht so, ja,
Und dann denkst du dir, naja, okay, jetzt ist der enttäuscht und beleidigt und am nächsten Tag hat er Schutz. Na gut, dann eben nicht. So, mit dem Ergebnis, mit dem Grand.
Weil man, weil man ihm gesagt hätte, ähm dann hätte, ja, dann hätte ja die Abstimmung über die Koalitionsvertrag keine Chance. Hat man ihm gesagt, macht er eigentlich irgendwas aus eigenem
Antrieb heraus, ihm wird gesagt, da halte ich mal aus dem Wahlkampf raus, irgendwie halt die mal hier raus. Machen wir diesmal mal jenes schlimm.
Aber mit dem Ergebnis, jetzt ist der Schulzeit weg, ja? Also der ist jetzt wirklich der ist jetzt weg.
Durch. Damit jetzt gar nichts mehr. Bürgermeister in Würselen vielleicht.
Ich glaube nicht,
Ich glaube, da hat er keine Chance. So, aber mit dem Ergebnis, weil der Gabriel äh nämlich in diesem Interview da irgendwie äh sich noch immer über den Schulz lustig gemacht hat,
irgendwie beleidigt war, sagt die SPD jetzt Freundchen, äh wenn du, wenn du uns bei der ersten Gelegenheit hier so außer außer Linie scherst, ne, dann wollen wir dich als Außenminister auch nicht mehr haben,
Das heißt, der hat sich, die haben beide ihre Brücken abgerissen, beide weg und Nahles sitzt da, die wird wahrscheinlich jetzt Parteivorsitzende, Vizekanzlerin, Fraktionsvorsitzende, Außenministerin, ähm.
Und selbst das kriegen sie nicht hin, weil,
Jetzt hat der Schulze gesagt, ja ja ich räume dann den Platz für Nahles und die SPD-Mitglieder sagen so ungefähr so Moment mal, ähm wer hier Parteivorsitzende ist,
ne? Da wollen wir vielleicht auch noch mal was zu sagen. Nicht, dass die was gegen Nahles hätten. Aber selbst
selbst zurücktreten kann der Typ nicht ordentlich, weil er dann direkt sagt, so ich räuch, ach so, hier, ich habe ja hier so einen Staffelstab, den habe ich dem Sigma weggenommen, den gebe ich jetzt hier der Andrea,
Meine Güte.
Ja. So, das heißt, das kann auch noch scheitern.
Dass wir also nach
da müssten sie jetzt irgendwie, da muss Finales jetzt halt sagen, na ja okay, ich mache das Kommissarisch eine Woche lang und ich äh will sofort dann danach einen Entscheid darüber haben. Ich will natürlich äh gewählt werden in dieses Amt so. Und dann wird sie das wahrscheinlich auch werden,
Wen soll den sonst wählen.
Kevin Schötert. Also, mich würde jetzt gar nichts mehr überraschen bei der SPD. Und da das ist ja auch das Schlimme da dran. Niemand würde jetzt überhaupt noch irgendwas überraschen,
So alles, ich meine uns geht's ja schon so ein bisschen länger so, ne? So dieser äh eigentlich schon wirklich total,
getropfte Unfallerwitz den man irgendwie immer wieder aus der Tasche zieht, wenn's um die SPD geht, so dieses
Ja ist doch klar, wie ihr euch verhaltet am Schluss, so ihr werdet halt alles widerrufen, was ihr gesagt habt so und jetzt blickst du einfach nur auf dieses letzte halbe Jahr auseinandersetzen so und keine,
einzige Ansage hat gestimmt.
Wie das geil ist.
Alles falsch.
Die haben nicht nur alles widerrufen, was sie gesagt haben, sondern das dann auch nochmal.
Ja, genau. Also noch noch nicht mal die Revision eines Urteils hält äh irgendwie länger. Also das ist Leute, echt, das geht einfach überhaupt.
Manchmal so so ich guck ja als Politikjunkie gucke ich natürlich auch diese ganzen Politikserien ne? Also was weiß ich
Westwing, House of Cards und solche Scherze, ne? Und manchmal guckst du dir das an und denkst dir so, oh, jetzt aber, jetzt geht's aber hier, ne? Das ist ja unglaublich äh wie das hier ähm
schwingt, ne, so von oh jetzt gerade so der war eigentlich alles gemacht, aber jetzt durch einen kleinen Fehler oder durch die eine Liste des politischen Gegners wird das ganze Blatt wieder gewendet und denkst dir so
Ja, das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen an Hahn herbeigezogen so, aber der Hahn muss ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen Spannung rein und dann guckst du SPD und denkst dir so, komm, ey, ist ein bisschen,
Jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben so, ne? Das äh unglaublich. Unglaublich.
Ja ja und vor allem das Haifischbecken, das ähm endet ja nicht bei der Sozialdemokratie. Meine CSU hat jetzt vielleicht grad so ein bisschen Verschnaufpause, solange bis sie halt wirklich mal wieder gefordert sind, was zu tun, was sie dann wahrscheinlich auch ein bissel lingen wird. Ähm,
Nur irgendwie bei der CDU Remords ja jetzt nun auch, weil die haben natürlich nicht die Traute da gleich äh so auf den Tisch zu hauen, aber so richtig glücklich sind die auch nicht.
Womit sind die nicht glücklich?
Naja, das das die Merkel sich halt irgendwie drei Haupt äh Ministerien abluchsen lassen von der SPD,
und auch aus und auch halt so langsam so dieser sanfte Wunsch dann doch vielleicht auch mal nicht nur die ganz alten Fressen da zu sehen. Ich meine was ist denn das für ein Line Lineup da, was was sie da haben? Das ist,
ein Gruselkabinett vor dem Herrn.
Das ist das äh erkennbare Problem äh die CDU wird sich darüber Gedanken machen müssen, wer denn Merkel beerben soll. Wenn die in vier Jahren ähm.
Nicht mehr antreten wird im Zweifelsfall oder vielleicht auch schon in wenigen Wochen, wenn äh Merkel tatsächlich feststellen muss, ich bin nicht in der Lage in der Region zu bilden.
Und es dann unter Umständen irgendeine Neuwahl geht, ja?
Das hat sie aber doch schon x-mal ausgeschlossen.
Das hat sie jetzt aber gerade in dem letzten Interview eigentlich implizit schon wieder äh.
Okay, dann.
Eingeräumt, dass das sehr wohl eine Option ist jetzt nicht direkt benannt, aber so ja, wenn das halt nicht klappt, dann wäre sie halt auch bereit.
Dann in vier Jahren musste muss sie spätestens in vier Jahren,
wird da jemand anders ran wollen, der braucht auch Erfolgsaussichten und da würde es sich anbieten, diese Person jetzt äh schon mal in einem der dankbareren Ministerämter äh vorzuwärmen,
und die Öffentlichkeit sich in der Öffentlichkeit feiern zu lassen, ne?
Eigentlich finde ich's äh weißt du schon, wie lange schon die Wahl her ist.
September oder?
Jetzt haben wir Mitte Februar.
Ist eigentlich auch so gelaufen, ne.
Ja. Also eigentlich können die sich jetzt noch, wenn ihr jetzt nicht noch dreieinhalb Jahre streiten, dann kann die AfD und da kann man die nichts durchkriegen, weil es wird auch einfach gar nichts beschlossen. Wirtschaft läuft.
Also du würdest du kannst quasi sagen so.
Einfach aussitzen.
Eigentlich relativ beruhigt so auch ohne Regierung machen wir keinen Fortschritt.
In Ordnung, so. Es ist okay, es bleibt alles, es bleibt auch ohne Regierung, bleibt alles beim Alten, ja?
Schauen wir mal in den äh Koalitionsvertrag. Ähm,
was wir da so haben. Der ist ja dann relativ schnell ähm vom vom Himmel gefallen als als Leck.
Ähm die.
Habe ehrlich gesagt äh den den wir zwar auch so ein bisschen durchgeschaut, aber ich äh nehme, ich nehme jetzt hier größtenteils Bezug auf die Zusammenfassung, die bei Netzpolitik Ork äh verfasst wurden, von dem ganzen Team, die sich ja jeweils auf ähm.
Auf einzelne Themenbereiche konzentriert haben. Ähm.
Eines der Probleme, die wir in diesem Land ja seit längerer Zeit haben, ist, dass im Prinzip der Infrastrukturausbau der digitale Infrastrukturausbau wirklich weit hinter den Versprechen,
zurückbleibt.
Viel zu teure, viel zu schlechte Internetverbindungen ähm und jetzt soll aber endlich mal was passieren, ne? Ähm es wird diskutiert, ein Recht auf schnelles Internet,
was äh.
Also das wird det wird natürlich dann wieder irgendwie zersägt werden. Sie wollen äh eine Vorreiterrolle im 5G-Ausbau haben und äh und Glasfaser wollen sie auch und Open Access, also lassen wir das mal ähm,
schön finde ich Thomas Rudel, der eigentlich der ja sehr analytisch äh an die Sachen rangeht ähm der
nimmt in letzter Zeit, also der der nimmt dieses Thema äh Infrastrukturausbau sehr ernst, wie wir alle
und sagt dann vor mir, nach zwei Ministerpleiten im Bundesministerium für Verkehr und digitale Infrastruktur in Klammern Peter Ramsauer und Alexander Dobrindt. Unternimmt die CSU nun einen weiteren Anlauf, um Deutschlands
digitale Infrastruktur, zukunftsfähig zu machen, also er hat sich auch, als ich auch unglaublich auf Dobrindt eingeschossen, in der er inzwischen auch schon vom Bundesrechnungshof für die katastrophale,
Führung des Ministeriums gerückt wurde, also alles Geld verbrannt, äh, ohne dass da irgendwas bei rausgekommen wur.
Kriegt er jetzt auch ein neues Ministerium, ne?
Ich muss gerade, ich habe gerade nicht vor mir liegen, die die ganzen Ministerien verteilen und das sollte ich eigentlich immer machen, weil ich habe mir das noch gar nicht.
Also er ist nicht mehr als Verkehrsminister, also das ist ja alles auch nur geraten, weil offiziell ist ja noch gar nichts, aber ich glaube, ist er fast gar nicht Landwirtschaft oder was irgendwas äh irgendwann hat die CSU noch bekommen, das soll er dann machen.
Äh also da werden wir, da kann man hoffen, ähm.
Voll Profis.
Dann das andere Ding, was mindestens genauso lange brach liegt in Deutschland, äh wie der digitale Infrastrukturausbau ist, die digitale Bildungsoffensive. Was ja eigentlich, dass.
Warte mal, vielleicht nochmal kurzer an, also ich habe halt nichts gehört. Also es war wieder irgendwas mit CSU hat ja schon gefordert, äh WLAN, überall bis zwanzig fünfzig.
Da war ich mir also das war ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ja.
Zwanzig fünfzehn kriegen wir WLAN in Bussen. Ich glaub der schönste Kommentar, den ich.
Fünfzig. Fünf. Fünfzig, ja. Ja.
Fünf fünfzig ja bis zweitausendfünfzig haben wir weder in allen Bussen und ich glaub der schönste Kommentar, den ich da auf Twitter zugekriegt, der war,
Zweitausendfünfzig in WLAN gerät äh betreibt, wird von der Bundespost sofort Gefangen genommen, weil die Frequenzen gar nicht genutzt werden dürfen,
So dass.
Formuliert, es war nämlich auch so meine Feststellung, dass das also gar nicht mehr so sicher ist, dass wir diese Technologie WLAN zwanzig fünfzig so überhaupt noch haben werden und wahrscheinlich sogar mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht. Da haben wir alle unsere acht G iPhones und äh läuft.
Ja das also komm, sowas nehme ich schon gar nicht mehr ernst, ne? Also.
Ja, aber ich meine, das, das ist, das muss man nur nochmal klar machen. Das ist der Level, auf dem da diskutiert wird. Und wenn die mir jetzt erzählen, dass sie eine Vorreiterrolle bei fünf G spielen wollen.
Ja, wie denn? Oder jetzt auch mit Glasfaser? Na ja, das ist klar.
Das bedeutet, das bedeutet letztendlich, also letztendlich, wenn,
Die Bundesrepublik sagt, die Bundesregierung sagt, wir möchten eine Vorreiterrolle im 5G-Ausbau haben, ja, dann heißt das, wir werden es den Unternehmen, die diesen betreiben, so angenehm wie möglich machen, diesen voranzubringen,
Und das bedeutet, wir werden den Steuererleichterungen äh geben oder wir werden mit den äh wir werden den lukrative äh Regulation,
angedeihen lassen, die es ihnen ermöglicht, äh diesen Infrastrukturausbau angenehm zu remonetarisieren.
Wenn sie die Frequenzen nicht wieder für so hüllisch viel Geld vertickern wollen.
Also was das bedeutet, wenn jetzt so eine Regierung sagt, wir wollen hier fünf G-Netze haben, dann die baut die ja nicht,
heißt, dass sie quasi durch entsprechende Regulation und Erleichterung es den Unternehmen ermöglichen wollen, äh diese
zu bauen, ja? Und so schreiben sie dann auch im Koalitionsvertrag, dafür ist eine gemeinsame Kraftanstrellung, Strengung von Telekommunikationsanbietern und Staat erforderlich. Wir gehen von einem öffentlichen Finanzierungsbedarf von zehn bis zwölf Milliarden Euro in dieser Legislaturperiode aus, die wir in
In einem Gigabit-Investitionsfonds verlässlich bereitstellen. Hierfür werden wir die Erlöse aus der Vergabe der UMTS und fünf G Lizenzen zweckgebunden bereitstellen und wollen bis zwanzig einundzwanzig im Haushalt sicherstellen, dass das Fördervolumen insgesamt erreicht wird,
Und dann sagen sie natürlich, dann binden sie diese Forderung, Förderung an bestimmte Bedingungen, ne? Muss irgendwie Kigabit ins ins aufs Land bringen und so versuchst du natürlich dann einfach über Anreize
und und Erleichterung und Förderung die Unternehmen dahin zu schubsen, dass sie sich was bauen, womit sie viel Geld verdienen können.
Ja, wird aber nicht funktionieren. Also wenn sie allein schon, ich meine, ich habe von das Wort Kooperationsverbot steht nicht in diesem Koalitionsvertrag.
Ist mir nicht bekannt, dass sie darüber sich Gedanken gemacht haben. Das wäre.
Hätte mich auch sehr überrascht, wenn sie sich mal Gedanken darüber machen würden, weil ich meine, das sind die eigentlichen Probleme. Das ist das, was verhindert, dass es in diesen Regionen keinerlei Infrastruktur gibt. Warum kann nicht die Telekom-Datenmast aufsetzen? Und das dann,
diese Frequenzen, die da bedient werden und und die Glasfaser, die da bedient wird, auch anderen äh zur Verfügung stellen. Warum steht auch nicht in diesem ich meine Glasfaser hin, Glasfaser her? Da steht nicht der Staat macht das.
Warum steht da nicht der Staat wird in
schlecht versorgten Gebieten selber für Infrastruktur sorgen und die zu gleichen Teilen einfach vermieten, damit noch irgendwie ein Haufen Asche äh machen im Zweifelsfall und äh vor allem für einen offenen Wettbewerb sorgen.
Ja, nee, das stimmt nicht zur Debatte.
Alles das sind doch alles totale No-Brainer und die stoßen ja noch nicht mal zu Nobrainern vor.
Brainless muss man sein, wenn man noch nicht mal zu Nobrainern kommt.
Ja und irgendwie dieses Recht auf Recht auf schnelles Internet, das wird ja auch irgendwie äh also dass das.
Das das der regelt ein Bundesgesetz. Also das das ist alles.
Die Idee ist natürlich, dass wenn du dann irgendwo bist und keine du kriegst kein vernünftiges Internet, kannst du dein, kannst du was weiß ich, die Telekom dazu verklagen und dann müssen die mit dem Bagger kommen und dir da irgendwie schnelles Internet machen.
Ja, aber schnelles Internet für die ist doch, das ist do.
Oder.
Ja, aber die haben doch überhaupt gar keine Vorstellung, was schnelles Internet ist. Die die reden noch davon, dass fünfzig Megabit pro Sekunde in eine Richtung,
Schnelles Internet sei, das ist nicht schnelles Internet, schnelles Internet ist wird überhaupt nicht in Megabit gemessen.
Ist das so. Ich meine, die Zeit rennt davon. Wenn du heute aufm Land, du hast da einen Laden,
auch nur so ansatzweise was digital machen soll, soll, soll sich ja langsam rumgesprochen haben, im Businessbereich, dass man auch mal was mit dem Internet macht, Sachen verkaufen zum Beispiel
bestellen irgendwie. Ich sage einfach nur die ganz normalen elektronischen Handel überhaupt mal durchzuführen. Von Backups der eigenen Daten, damit irgendwie nicht alles äh das ganze Unternehmen hops geht, wenn da mal ein Brand ausbricht. Mal,
ganz davon abgesehen. Ist ja durchaus ein Thema und ähm
Das ist überhaupt nicht eingepreist und wie soll in so einer Region Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Brandenburg, keine Ahnung, irgendwas reinlanden,
Es gibt so viele Regionen, die einfach komplett abgehängt sind, nicht nur im Osten. Da kannst du einfach gar kein Business mehr machen. Und das ist das, was ich nicht verstehe,
wir müssen uns nicht über Gigabit unterhalten. Wir müssen uns über eine Terrabit-Infrastruktur in Deutschland unterhalten und nicht megabits, Trickle, Trickle, Down, irgendwo hier ja, aber sieht. Freuen sie sich doch, sie können doch jetzt hier die Webseite anklicken,
Die denken doch einfach nicht weiter.
Ja, also vor allem im Vergleich halt zu dem.
Also wie weit wir im internationalen Vergleich schon zurück sind, also in Sachen Preis, in Sachen Leistung, die wir für dieses Geld bekommen. Dieses Land wird,
mittelfristig verkacken. Das ist nicht weiter zurückfallen, sondern das ist Untergehen,
Das ist irgendwie, dass es dann tatsächlich so, dass irgendwann in Geschichtsbücher stehen wird so. Ja, so, ne? Ich hatte das glaube ich schon mal gesagt, so der Höhepunkt der Digitalisierung war in Deutschland mit der Manipulation von,
Diese Motorsteuergeräten erreicht. Ab dann ging's bergab. So mehr wusste det Land,
aus dieser Sache nicht mehr zu machen, hat er aber auch nichts. Hat sich auch nichts gebaut, was man damit machen könnte, ne? Hatte kein Internet,
fallen. Irgendwann äh das Mut, da war mal ein Land. Da haben mal Menschen gewohnt, dass das Land nannte sich Deutschland.
Zehn Jahre vorher haben.
Aber die hatten kein Internet, deswegen sind die dann da weggezogen die Mensch.
Ja, zehn Jahre vorher hatten sie noch eine Leittechnologie. Da waren sie bei Solar tatsächlich noch irgendwie dran, bevor sie das irgendwie auch alles nach China ausgelagert haben. Ist wirklich ähm macht einen fassungslos und dann reden die immer so viel von Wirtschaft,
Ist doch alles Blödsinn, was ihr da redet.
Dann muss man dazu noch sagen,
das an. Also warum Deutschland digital kein Vorreiter ist? Ja wir haben nicht die wir haben nicht die Infrastruktur dafür,
Wir haben aber auch tatsächlich nicht die die Leute dafür, nicht die nicht die Fachkräfte dafür, ne? Der soll jetzt wieder eine Bildungsoffensive geben,
Die digitale Bildungsoffensive, die wurde zweitausenddreizehn schon groß angekündigt?
Ist jetzt auch die gleiche nochmal. Ähm aber jetzt mit dem Versprechen, dass das oder mit der.
Mit dem Hintergrund, dass sie diesmal vielleicht funktionieren könnte. Denn ähm.
Das Problem bei der Bildungspolitik und bei der Unterstützung,
der Bildungspolitik durch den Bund, ist das Bildung Ländersache ist. Und das wiederum bedeutet, dass sie letztes, also momentan ist es so, der Bund darf finanzschwachen Gemeinden helfen,
und sagen hier holt euch mal schnelles Internet.
Nein, soweit, soweit geht es nicht.
Und das wollen sie jetzt im Zweifelsfall so quasi ausbohren und sagen, mit einer größeren Investitionsinitiative,
sollen ähm.
Unter anderem irgendwie Ganztagsschul- und Betreuungsangebote äh und so weiter ausgerollt werden und der Digitalpakt Raute D. Soll jetzt umgesetzt werden.
Nein,
Oh Gott, wirklich. Oh, sie haben einen Hashtag. Und sie werden.
Dotierten Digitalpackt Raute D,
zielen bunt und Länder auf die flächendeckende, digitale Ausstattung aller Schulen, damit die Schüler Schülerinnen,
Schüler in allen Fächern und Lärmbereichen eine digitale Lernumgebung nutzen können,
In diesem Zusammenhang wollen wir eine nationale Bildungsplattform schaffen, die auch eine offene Schnittstelle für das Zusammenwirkung zusammenwirken mit bestehenden Lernplattformen und Cloud-Lösungen anbietet. Im Rahmen einer umfassenden Open Educational Resources
Strategie,
wollen wir die Entstehung und Verfügbarkeit, die Weiterverbreitung und den didaktisch fundierten Einsatz offener, offen lizensierter, frei zugänglicher Lehr und Lernmaterialien fördern und eine geeignete Qualitätssicherung etablieren,
auch werden wir die regionalen regionale Kompetenzzentren,
Für Digitalisierung etablieren und diese mit bestehenden Akteuren und Initiativen vor Ort vernetzen. Ziel der Zentren ist es, technisches und pädagogisches Know-How zu vermitteln, sowie best Practice vorzustellen,
Wenn ich diesen Text ähm neunzehnhundertneunzig gelesen hätte, hätte ich gesagt, boah.
Das klingt wie all das, was man nun tun muss. Wurde aber nicht getan und ähm,
Jetzt können wir eben nur hoffen, dass es irgendwann mal passiert, ja,
Der Digitalpakt, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, das sind dann auch immer nur so einstellige Milliardenbeträge,
Das wäre ja erstaunlich, wenn man das jetzt äh am Ende mit einem mit ein paar wenigen Milliarden auf einmal in die Reihe kriegt, aber was ich so höre und ähm,
Hier sei auch nochmal verwiesen auf äh das, was so die Erfahrung von Chaos macht, Schule und anderen Initiativen sind,
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie die ganzen Schulen mal irgendwie in das einundzwanzigste Jahrhundert updaten möchtest, dann musst du natürlich auch das Lehrpersonal dafür haben. Das heißt, du äh musst vor zehn, fünfzehn Jahren.
Eine entsprechende ein entsprechendes Fundament in der Ausbildung des Lehrpersonals gelegt haben.
Das ist glaube ich nicht geschehen. Kann man da im Lehrpersonal jetzt keine äh Schuld dran geben? Die hätten das in,
Prinzip vielleicht in einer Eigeninitiative noch hinkriegen können, gibt's ja auch,
Leerkörper, die das tun, die da herausragendes Engagement zeigen und irgendwelche AGs in,
Am Nachmittag anbieten oder äh das so schon in den in den Unterricht einfließen lassen. Aber da hängt,
So viel dran. Da geht los mit wenn das jetzt einfach Lehrer in ihr und Lehrerinnen in ihrer Freizeit machen, ja? Dann hast du da keine allgemeine Qualitätsstandard drin. Das heißt
Ne, die einen machen das so, die anderen machen das so, die die einhalten das für wichtig, die anderen halten das für sie für wichtig mit anderen Worten. Du hast keine garantierten,
Kein garantiertes Minimum, was ein, was einem Kind zugute kommt, ja? Blicke hier immer nur auf die Benachteiligten am Ende, ja? Ähm,
Wenn jetzt die Leute sagen, ah wir machen aber jetzt hier mit Digitalisierung,
Musst du dir anschauen, in welchem Rahmen passiert das denn, ja? Wie soll der, wie findet das statt, wie gleichst du die schon existierenden, großen, sozialen Unterschiede,
in den unter den Kindern aus, die das größte Problem in unserem Land,
Ich hab wir haben alles ist das größte Problem. Unser Land ist das größte Problem aber die eines der großen Probleme in unserem Land sind das ist im Prinzip was weiß ich Einkommen der Eltern der beste Predigtor für.
Äh ähm für deinen späteren,
Bildungsverlauf und dann späteren Einkünfte ist. Das heißt, da musst du ein Konzept haben, wie du's schaffst dafür zu sorgen, dass diese digitale Bildung,
ähm nicht mehr an das Einkommen der Eltern gebunden ist und da ist natürlich dann, wenn du das so lange äh,
nicht gemacht hast, steht äh steht im Raume, dass natürlich dann sowas kommt wie Google und sagt, hör mal ähm,
Wollt ihr nicht mal hier einfach mit unserem Lehrprogramm arbeiten? Und die werden auch tatsächlich das Beste auf dem Markt machen, weil,
Du in deinem ganzen Land keine vernünftigen Programmierer mehr hast, weil die alle schon ausgewandert sind. Ne,
Ich rede jetzt hier auf auf dem großen landesweiten Niveau. Natürlich gibt's gute Programmierer in Deutschland. Aber werden die am Ende irgendwie Tabletapplikationen für den,
für den
Für die erste Klasse machen? Nein, am Ende sind dann die die von allen preisgekrönten Programmier-Lehrprogramme ist dann sowas wie wie Apple mit seinem wie heißt das? Playgrounds, ne? Äh wo wo
mal eben so ein Konzern ein paar Millionen in der Hand genommen hat und ein vernünftiges Programm dafür geschrieben hat, wo man wie man die, wie man programmieren,
wie man lernt, wie ein Programmierer zu denken und zwar spielerisch und zwar so, dass das in der Grundschule funktioniert, ja? Solche Dinge alles.
Ja. Also ich meine, ich.
Und wenn das nicht organisch wächst, dann kriegst du das nicht mehr hin.
Also ich würde,
Man kann das natürlich jetzt man kann darauf verweisen, aber ich würde Ihnen jetzt, ich würde jetzt einer neuen Koalition, einer neuen Regierung, die ja wohl auch teilweise aus neuen, teilweise, aus neuen Leuten besteht und die auch immer eine neue Chance haben muss.
Kann man jetzt nicht vorwerfen, na ja äh das hilft ja alles nix, weil vor fünfzehn Jahren und so weiter, das klingt ja dann so fatalistisch mit äh ihr braucht auch überhaupt gar nicht mehr mit irgendwas ankommen. Es hilft ja alles gar nichts mehr. So ist es ja nun auch nicht,
aber um das auch gleich nochmal ein paar andere Sachen äh aufzumachen
Diese ganze, ich meine diese diese Initiative ist ja nichts Neues. Das hat ja die Vanca schon vor einem Jahr, glaube ich, angekündigt, dieses, wir nehmen jetzt mal Geld in die Hand und schmeißen halt die Kohle drauf, mir das schon richtig sagte, Bildung ist eigentlich Ländersache. Da haben sie es halt über diesen Umweg
na ja, aber Infrastruktur können wir ja vielleicht mal ausbauen, versucht nur die Ankündigung jetzt in Schulen sorry.
Äh eine Ladung iPads abzuschmeißen, Parotta in der Ecke äh zu installieren und vielleicht wenn's gut läuft äh auch nochmal eine Internetleitung äh die,
Namen verdient. Stellt diese Schulen für vor noch größere Probleme, weil wie du schon richtig sagtest, erstens das Personal nicht da ist,
was den Lehrer allein die Lehrer betrifft, die Ausbildung der Lehrer, die Prägung der Lehrer, das hier muss man tatsächlich von,
neuen Lehrerbild auch ausgehen, was ich.
Neue Erfindung der Schule.
Was, was, was, ah, es muss nicht alles neu sein, aber es muss ähm,
Man muss schon mal äh massiv drauf hinwirken, dass da einfach eine eine breite Kompetenz aufgebaut wird. Allein, damit die notwendige Debatte,
innerhalb der der Bildungsgemeinschaft selber auch auf anderen Füßen steht als derzeit wo es halt einfach nur so ein paar ausgewählte,
Lehrer Nörd sind, die sich da intensiv drüber unterhalten und da gibt's natürlich genauso eine eine
eine eingeweihte Szene, die seit Jahren versucht äh irgendwas nach vorne zu bringen. Aber das, das hat einfach alles noch nicht die Breite und schon gar nicht diese Tiefe
Aber es geht ja weiter. Ich meine, wenn da jetzt ein paar iPads drauf wirfst, die dann nach zwei, drei Jahren auch schon wieder Veralterungserscheinungen zeigen
Wer aktualisiert die, also
Kohle für 'ne einmalige Ausgabe hilft erstmal niemanden weiter weil die Dinger müssen administriert werden, die die müssen irgendwie repariert werden, gewartet werden, weiterentwickelt werden, da muss 'ne Perspe
Tiefe auch dahinter sein
Und ehrlich gesagt, so offentlich für digitale Lehrkonzepte bin, denke ich halt jetzt auch nicht, dass dieses, na ja, jetzt ist die Schule voll mit Computern, jetzt wird alles gut, das da kommt, das ist nicht die Lösung, äh, die wir brauchen.
Aber das ist das wird auf jeden Fall schon mal das Fundament dafür sein und wenn das der Bund nun die Länder unterstützen kann dabei,
dann immerhin. Ja, also ist ja schon mal gut. Es war ja schon sehr skurril, äh wie offenbar teilweise da die äh,
dem Bund die Hände,
gebunden waren, ja? Das wird eben jetzt mit diesem Digitalpackt D kann der Bund dann die Länder finanziell bei der technischen Modernisierung der Schulen unterstützen. Dafür wird der Bund
Geld bereitstellen und darüber, wofür dieses Geld bereitgestellt wird, kann man da sehr viel steuern. Ne, das äh da werden jetzt ein paar iPads abgeladen, sagen wir so daher, ne. Ähm.
Das wird sich dann natürlich zeigen und wie das im Detail sein wird, wie das ausgestaltet wird, steht ja dann in so einem Koalitionsvertrag auch noch nicht wirklich drin, ne? Wir werden wir also sehen, was sie dann machen. Schön ist immerhin, sie haben dran gedacht,
Das muss man auch mal loben. Fleiß, kriegst du ein fleißiges Bienchen.
Ja gut. Immerhin haben sie zwei, drei schon mal getickt, die ganz okay sind. Aber.
Überwachung und innere Sicherheit haben sie auch ein paar Baskets getickt,
Ähm sehr schöne Feststellung, viel mehr muss man da auch gar nicht hinzufügen. Das Wort Bürgerrechte kommt im Koalitionsvertrag von Union und SPD immerhin vor,
Einmal. Ähm Sicherheit in all ihren Facetten und Teilwörtern,
wird dafür ganze einhundertneunundfünfzig Mal genannt, stellt Markus Reuter von Netzpolitik Org fest. Ähm,
siebeneinhalbtausend Stellen zur finanziellen und personellen Ausweitung von Geheimdienst und Polizei. Erleichterter Datenaustausch zwischen
den unterschiedlichen Institutionen, Bund und Ländern, Polizeien und Geheimdiensten und mit europäischen Ermittlungsbehörden,
Natürlich steht da noch nicht dabei mit welchen Befugnissen und Pflichten, dass in diesem,
Koalition das das stattfinden soll, wie gesagt, das ist ein Koalitionsvertrag, kein äh kein Gesetzesentwurf, aber da werden Sie sich weiter drüber Gedanken machen,
Und das Bundeskriminalamt soll zum zentralen Datenhaus werden. Äh das heißt, die IT-Infrastruktur und die Standards aller Polizeien sollen äh vereinheitlicht werden unter der Egide des,
BKA, dafür braucht man mal eben einen dreistelligen Millionenbetrag. Ähm.
Also das klingt jetzt erstmal nach einer infrastrukturellen Maßnahme. Ähm jetzt muss man sich natürlich noch überlegen, wie man damit noch ein, wie man da noch einen Grundrechtsabbau mit reinkriegt, geht ganz einfach,
du weitest den Datenaustausch zum Beispiel bei sogenannten Gefährdern aus, Gefährder, also Leute, die noch keine Straftat äh begangen haben, äh die du aber verdächtigst in Zukunft eine zu begehen. Da werden die soll also eine,
soll der Datenaustausch ausgeweitet werden,
dann natürlich äh Videoüberwachung muss auch ausgewertet ausgewertet werden und äh der Einsatz der Kameras als automatisierter identifizierungs- und Verhaltensscanner,
ist ins Auge gefasst, also die intelligente Videoüberwachung, wo äh die, ne, also Südkreuz war ja ein Erfolg, wie Thomas Demizier schon feststellte,
und das muss man natürlich weitermachen, wäre schade, wenn man da nicht noch mehr rocken könnte,
In einem früheren Verhandlungsstand des Koalitionsvertrages sollte diese Staatstrojaner Geschichte nochmal revidiert werden. Ähm.
Das ist äh leider verschwunden. Ähm also die,
Staatstriana bleibt und äh außerdem finden sich dann auch so schöne Sätze drin, wie es soll keinen Unterschied machen,
Ob die Nutzer sich zur Kommunikation der klassischen Telefonie oder klassischer SMS bedienen oder ob sie auf internetbasierte Messengerdienste ausweichen,
Das war diese Argumentation war einer der zehn war eines der zentralen Argumente für die.
Letzte für das letzte Staatstrojaner, für den letzten Staatstruaner Vorschuss, der letzte Staatstrianer Vorschuss, bei dem ging es ja darum, ähm den den Staatstrojaner auch in der Alltagskriminalität nutzen zu können. Also äh,
Wir harten Staatstrianer schon länger gegen Terroristen.
Und äh schwere Vergehen, jetzt ging es darum, wir wollen staatstrojaner,
im Prinzip auch im im normalen Ermittlungsverfahren benutzen können. Und zwar hier nicht den Online-Durchsuchungsstaatszwanger, der im Prinzip auf alles zu Zugang hat, sondern die,
Idee des Quellen, Telekommunikationsüberwachung, Staatstrojaners und zwar ein spezifischer Trojaner, der,
Realexistent noch nicht gesehen wurde, der aber theoretisch nur zu dem Zweck dienen soll
Kommunikationswege zu überwachen, die verschlüsselt erfolgen. Und da haben sie ja quasi genau das gesagt, haben gesagt, äh wir wollen, wenn wir nach Paragraph SDPO hundert noch was sagen, wir hören jetzt das Telefon ab,
oder die SMS und die Leute nutzen aber dann WhatsApp, dann läuft unsere Anordnung ins Leere. Und deswegen wollen wir diesen Staatssyana im normalen,
Ermittlungsverfahren auch haben. Das war das, wo ich letztes Jahr, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, war das nochmal ähm Sachverständiger, war auch im Deutschen Bundestag zu dem Thema.
Der gleiche Satz findet sich jetzt aber wieder da drin wo was ein was uns wundern lässt, weil das im Zweifelsfall dann heißt na ja,
Dann wollen sie wahrscheinlich auch noch eine eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung dafür haben, weil das ist das, was gerade noch diese Kommunikationswege unterscheidet. Äh wenn man sagt, es darf keinen Unterschied zwischen WhatsApp und SMS geben.
Dann haben sie auch noch da drin, dass sie äh irgendwie die ähm ausgeweitete DNA-Analyse machen wollen. Ähm,
zum Beispiel auch zu zur Feststellung des Aussehens. Also da gab's einen sehr schönen Vortrag auch beim Kongress zu von Adora Bell mit dem Titel Extended DNA Nalaces. Den äh wir auch in den Shownotes verlinken. Ähm um die Schwächen dieses Verfahren
Verfahrens. Ähm,
Da kannst du also quasi mit mittels eines DNA einer DNA-Analyse sagen, ja die Person ist im Zweifel zwar männlich dunkelhaarig oder sowas, ja. Und diese.
Aus dieser Aussage ist aber natürlich mit einer,
ist mit einer Fehlertoleranz behaftet. Und deswegen spricht sich, spricht man eigentlich sehr da sich dagegen aussprechen, Experten sich dagegen aus solche Ergebnisse überhaupt der Polizei zu geben.
Weil die Polizei dann natürlich geneigt sein wird, zu sagen, ah äh der Täter hat dunkle Haare äh,
Wir haben es an einem Zollstock gemessen oder wie war dieser schöne DNA-Fall da, wo sie? Äh der ist doch jetzt auch irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre her, wo sie irgend so einen Menschen.
Also Verschmutzung von von.
Ja da hatten sie doch irgendwie am Ende DNA-Spuren von einem Täter an irgendwie ganz vielen verschiedenen
komischen Fällen und haben dann gesagt, oh, Durchbruch, wunderbar, wir ziehen den jetzt hier raus und am Ende stellte sich fest, dass das eine kontaminierter
Messstapfer, den der quasi der Fotograf oder so mit in die Bilder legt, damit man quasi in dem Bild so ein, so ein,
Zollstock liegen hat, wo dran steht, das sind jetzt hier zehn Zentimeter. Und damit hatten sie dann irgendwie zwei so seit Jahrzehnten ungeklärte Mordfälle auf einmal. So, oh mein Gott, so gelöst und eine Woche später dann so, ah nee doch nicht.
Also damit ihnen sowas nicht passiert. Aber das wollen sie also auch haben.
Und da kann man sich äh wie gesagt, warum dieses Verfahren äh kritisiert wird, dazu sei der der Vortrag äh empfohlen.
Urheberrecht? Gibt's auch noch? Da ist der Leonard Dobusch bei Netzwerk Oc verhalten, positiv gestimmt.
Und sagt immerhin keine Uploadfilter,
Der Satz lautet, eine Verpflichtung von Plattformen zum Einsatz von Upload-Filtern, um von Nutzern hochgeladene Inhalte nach Urberichtsfall letzten Inhalten zu filtern, lehnen wir als unverhältnismäßig ab.
Dann gibt's noch schön die Frage natürlich ja was mit Leistungsschutzrecht. Ja sagen sie im Urheberrecht unterstützen wir nachdrücklich eine zeitnahe Regelung zu Verlegerbeteiligung,
Bei den Verwertungsgesellschaften und stärken die Positionen der Verleger auf europäischer Ebene durch eine eigene Rechtsposition. Sagt Leonard Dobusch ähm,
Das klingt nach Leistungsschutzrecht, ja? Insbesonders zeitnah äh Verlegerbeteiligung,
Bei den Verwertungsgesellschaften, aber Julia Reder sagt, die er da sehr drin hängt, auch auf EU-Ebene,
Ähm da eher ein Einblick hat Satz, die vermutet, dass das äh,
für für die Rechtsdurchsetzung, für Vermutungsregeln, spricht, das heißt, wenn ein äh.
Das hat sie besser erklärt, als sie hier zu Gast war. Im Prinzip, dass es leistungsschutzrecht da halt nicht als ein Recht tatsächlich klar ist, aber dass dass ein Verleger in bestimmten,
rechtlichen Ansprüchen ist einfach vor Gericht, weil er eine Vermutungsregel zu seinen Gunsten hat.
Also eine ähm die alternative Vermutungsriegel, die der Rat gerade diskutiert. Und ansonsten freut der Leonard sich auch über für sein Recht auf Remix, weil ähm,
moderne Nutzungsformen in das System der Vergütung für gesetzlich erlaubte Nutzungen mit einfließen sollen,
Also mit anderen Worten eine Aufweitung der äh was darf man, was ist vom Urheberrecht
geschützt äh oder welche. Was ist zwar vom Urheberrecht geschützt und was darf aber was stellt keine, welche geringfügige
Verstoß stellt kein Verstoß gegen dieses Urheberrecht mehr dar, ja? Also Fair-Use solche Geschichten.
Ja, ich traue den Braten nicht.
Also ich.
Das ist doch alles. Damals wusste er so schnell wieder hin.
Damals wusste, also als die ganzen Analysen äh geschrieben wurden, ich Koalitionsvertrag ist immer so eine Sache. Man weiß dann wenigstens was auf einen zukommt.
Zukommen könnte. Jetzt stellt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, kommt diese Koalition auf diesem, auf diesem Wege zustande? Ähm wir wissen, dass häufig äh in den späteren.
In den späteren Zeiten der Legislatur. Viel noch.
Diskutiert wird und reingeschoben wird, weil es ja nun mal so im Koalitionsvertrag steht,
Ne? Anfangs machen sie, machen sie dann, denken sie, ah, wir haben ja noch Zeit, machen wir erstmal was hier gerade irgendwie. Machen wir ein bisschen Tagespolitik und was uns so um die Nase fliegt. Und am Ende wird dann hastig noch schnell versucht, durchzuprügeln
was ja noch im Koalitionsvertrag stand. Insofern ist das keine schlechte.
Ist es nicht schlecht, da mal reinzublicken, aber wir werden's am Ende äh beurteilen müssen, wie es dann wirklich konkret ausgestaltet wird, wenn es um,
darum geht, dass das hier jetzt auch passiert, dass das mit Leben äh gefüllt werden soll, was hier versprochen werden soll wird. Insofern Koalitionsverträge können immer so ein bisschen äh alles und nichts bedeuten am Ende,
scheitern solche Gesetze ja gerne auch mal im Detail.
So sieht's aus. Also wir werden abwarten, ob dieser Koalitionsvertrag überhaupt irgendwie mit Leben be,
werden kann. So, ob es dann letztlich auch wird, dass wenn er beschlossen wird, ist nochmal eine andere Frage, aber ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal so richtig sicher, dass wir diese SPD, die CDU-Koalition sehen werden und selbst wenn wir sie sehen werden,
was die überhaupt noch für eine Power hat. Also das ist, das mag dann zwar so eine Mehrheit haben.
So diese ganze äh fortgeschrittene Zersetzung der SPD. Ich weiß nicht.
Also ich meine, es kann auch eine ja also SPD gut, ne? SPD ist, jetzt ist jetzt erstmal durch das Ding, ne? Aber ähm,
Was mich tatsächlich mehr ähm irritiert ist.
Dass im Moment noch existierende Machtvakuum hinter Merkel. Und alle beklagen das ja so ein bisschen. Vielleicht ist aber auch ein Blick darauf, äh dass Merkel da klug, so klug ist
sich nicht einzumischen und quasi,
ohne einen ohne eine Präferenz da reingeht und sagt, okay, ich regiere jetzt hier noch irgendwie schön zu Ende,
Ich sehe zu, dass ich vielleicht ein paar wichtige Initiativen vielleicht noch mit auf den Weg kriege und dann sollen die sollen die sich unter mir vier Jahre lang äh ruhig mit den Messern aufeinander losgehen.
Das vielleicht äh ist das, also vielleicht ist das ihre Taktik, ja? Vielleicht ist das die Strategie und es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe es in der CDU nicht vielleicht auch Menschen,
denen diese den das ein oder andere Thema zumindest, was jetzt hier irgendwie Digitalisierung und nach vorne schreiten nicht vielleicht doch,
auch am Herzen liegt.
Ja, aber was hat das schon gebracht bisher wenig? Also warten wir es mal ab. Ich.
Also irgendeiner wird die wird diese wird die kommende Koalition dann schon hetzen, ja? Irgendeiner wird die schon scheuchen und seien es dann eben FDP und Grüne.
Und der CDU-Nachwuchs. Kann auch sein.
Na die AfD hat natürlich die besten Reden, ne? Weiterhin mit dem Repertoire von Netzpolitikorg ankommen geht da richtig was.
Ey, dann dann wird, dann werden die sich noch wundern, dann prüft die AfD nachher die Digitalisierung durch. Na ja.
So, aber wir haben ja dann noch den Verfassungsschutz.
Ja in in Hessen,
wurde das Gesetz zur Neuausrichtung des Verfassungsschutzes äh diskutiert. Interessant ist, warum wir, warum ich das nochmal behandeln möchte ist, wir haben in Hessen eine schwarz-grüne,
Landesregierung, ja? Die und die Grüne, der Grüne Teil der schwarz-grünen Landesregierung war natürlich nicht da wirklich so,
so dagegen ist es so dafür. Diskutiert wurden in Hessen in dieser Neuausrichtung des Verfassungsschutzes insbesondere natürlich Staatstrojaner,
Parlamentarische Kontrolle und die Regeln unter den äh V-Leute eingesetzt werden und auch die Idee einer Gesinnungsprüfung.
Für äh für Menschen, die innen staatlich geförderten ähm Demokratisierungsprojekten sind. Doch ich gehe erstmal
der Reihe nach durch. Staatstrojaner sollen die Landesgeheimdienstler bekommen, da ist mal wieder das TKÜ-Phänomen, ja? Also der,
Quellentickerütrojaner, sie sagen, also ja, wir können die nicht, wir können nicht mehr alle Gespräche abhören, die nutzen Kommunikationsmittel, die nicht abhörbar sind und deswegen müssen wir die jetzt abhörbar machen. Dafür wollen wir sie an der Quelle abhören mit einem quasi mittels
Trojanisierung der Endgeräte und da ist natürlich klar, ob das ob ein Quellenticker-Ütrojaner das,
Vor allem nur das tut, was er darf, ist wahrscheinlich technisch sowieso schon kaum umzusetzen und es ist noch schwerer, das zu kontrollieren. Und deswegen ist das Verfassungsmäßig auch so äh kompliziert.
Weiterhin äh das Argument, was sicher auch immer äh hier in den Vordergrund stelle, wenn man,
Trojaner, Trojaner anbringen möchte, braucht man dafür Schwachstellen und,
Hier bringt auch Hannes Federat äh das wichtige Argument nochmal. Der Staat ist in der Pflicht Anreize für die Meldung und Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitslücken zu schaffen durch den Staatstrianer entsteht genau das Gegenteil, also Unsicherheit,
für alle wir opfern hier im Prinzip die innere Sicherheit aller äh für wie ja selbst die,
Strafverfolger und die Geheimnisse sagen, einige wenige Fälle, in denen sie da mal äh das zur Anwendung bringen wollen.
Parlamentarische Kontrolle wird in Hessen die,
die haben im Prinzip die Möglichkeiten der Oppositionsfraktionen so begrenzt äh,
Das noch nicht einmal alle fünf Parteien in dem Kontrollgremium für die Geheimdienste vertreten werden. Ja, also.
Und irgendwie keine Minderheiten voten und so. Also da eher juristische, juristische Themen.
Also was ist da das Kriterium irgendwie, also es gibt einfach nicht genug Plätze und deswegen können.
Ja, das haben sie jetzt erstmal so geschrieben und jetzt kommen halt die Verfassungsrechtler und die Juristen und sagen Freunde, guckt euch mal bitte eure Verfahren an, dass äh das ist die parlamentarische Kontrolle, habt ihr da so beschnitten, dass noch nicht mal
dass in der hessischen Kontrollkommission nicht mal alle fünf Parteien vertreten sind
Und jetzt müsst ihr mal überlegen, wie das hier äh wie das hier laufen soll, ne? Wenn die da da müssen also.
Bessere Kontrollbefugnisse für das Parlament geschaffen werden. Ähm solche Einwände sind in der Regel die, die durchkommen,
ja äh dass du sagst, okay, da muss wenigstens auf dem Papier gut aussehen. Die Kontrolle wird am Ende dann eh nicht funktionieren. Äh da geht's nämlich dann auch noch ähm um solche Themen wie ähm,
haben die vor dem Kontrollgremium die zu kontrollierenden Berichtspflicht und hast du,
Ein Recht auf Einsicht oder haben die Akten auch weiterzugeben, ja? Also musst du da irgendwie hinfahren und darfst dann unter,
mal schauen oder kriegst du auch die Akten zum Studium, um mit deinen Mitarbeitern und Mitarbeiterinnen äh dir die zu Gemüte zu führen. Aber sowas geht in der Regel sowas, da ändern die meistens,
mit solchen Einwänden kommt man ganz gerne mal durch.
Nicht zu sehr mit den äh unter anderem übrigens auch vom Chaos-Computerclub Darmstadt da vorgetragenen und mitverfassten Argumenten aus technischer äh und Grund,
recht Rechtsperspektive. Dann äh die der Einsatz von Fahrleuten ist ein interessantes Thema in Hessen, denn der frühere Spitzname,
Herr Gärtner und sein Vormann-Führer Andreas Temme.
Der frühere was? Spitze.
Ja, also also ein der V-Mann, Herr Gärtner und der Vormann-Führer, Herr Theme, ähm die haben.
Stehen bei dieser stehen bei in dieser NSU komplex NSU-Sache in Hessen im Mittelpunkt, denn der,
Theme, also der Vormann-Führer war kurz vor oder während des Mordes an Halid Yozgat zweitausendsechs in Kassel am Tatort.
Ähm und mit dem ähm Gärtner
der Rechtsextreme hatte Theme am gleichen Tag länger telefoniert. Also die die
die streicheln die diese V-Leute und ihre Führer streichen da so irgendwie um die NSU-Tatorte und so herum und ähm da muss man natürlich sofort eine Lösung herbeiführen und das ist
Straffreiheit für V-Leute, ja? Ähm!
Klassische Antwort.
Klassischer Fall.
Weil wie das war verboten, ne? Dann müssen wir das äh.
Genau, die brauchen also jetzt die brauchen brauchen Straffreiheit. Ich versuche das Argument mal so nachzuvollziehen, dass sie sagen, na ja, wenn wir den Straffreiheit zusichern, dann kriegen wir mehr Informationen,
weil sie dann eben auch unter Umständen sich selbst äh belasten können ähm sich selbst belasten können,
in der Aufklärung, ne, zum Ziele höre. Das ist glaube ich der ein Argument, aber es ist natürlich auch wieder
Skurril. Wenn du wenn du deine Lösung dafür muss ja sein, wenn deine V-Leute da irgendwie mit dem ML NSU rumrum äh gammeln äh und irgendwie über über Jahrzehnte du da irgendwelche fürchterlichen Morde nicht aufgeklärt kriegst. Dann musst du einfach mal fragen, ob du weiter
diesen Leuten Geld geben muss oder ob die, ob vielleicht das gesamte Programm sein Geld nicht wertvoll und einfach eine eine ziemlich schlechte Idee.
Diesen gleichen Gedanken machen die sich äh allerdings natürlich bei äh Beratungsstellen und Projekten die,
für die Demokratieförderung,
eingesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel gibt es natürlich so äh Demokratiestärken, Initiativen und so weiter. Dann hast du ja äh irgend so eine Bürgerinitiative oder ein Jugendzentrum oder so und die kriegen dann für einen, kriegen dann zum Beispiel so ein Projekt gefördert, wo sie eine,
ge
gegen Nazis. Oder gegen gegen rechtes Gedankengut vorgehen als Begegnungsstätte mit in was weiß ich in der Ausstellung weiß der Geier, wofür du alles Förderung bekommen kannst, wenn du dich,
Wenn das Ziel deines Projektes irgendwie Bildung, Aufklärung oder sonst was gegen äh fremdenfeindliches Gedankengut ist, ja.
Da sagen sie, ja aber die Leute, die in solchen Projekten und Beratungsstellen arbeiten, die würden wir ganz gerne äh überprüfen können,
Ja, da die müssen sich nämlich bitteschön ähm die müssen bitteschön zeigen,
dass sie der freiheitlich demokratischen Grundordnung zugetan sind. Und nicht, dass das nah, nicht das hier nachher, dass wir nachher Linksextreme,
äh in den Projekten haben, die Bildungsarbeit gegen Rechtsextreme widmen und deswegen, ne? Klar, wer Deutsch, wer vom vom Staat gefördert wird, der muss natürlich hier auch den,
der muss sich einer Gesinnungsprüfung unterziehen lassen. Hatten wir übrigens auch schon mal in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland? Viele Jahre,
ähm für für Lehrer und Beamte, ja, die dann äh das das hieß damals doch Berufsverbote übrigens, ne? Das.
Nicht in der KPD sein durften.
Gott durfte es in bestimmten Parteien nicht sein und das war eine eine großartige Zeit,
kenne ich übrigens einen Podcast, äh drüber, den ich vor einiger Zeit gehört habe, die ich da auch nochmal raushöre, denn nämlich Jahre her ähm.
Metrolaut äh heißt der Podcast glaube ich, die hatten da jemanden zu Gast, der darüber eine Doktorarbeit geschrieben hatte, ähm über wie diese Berufsverbote
funktioniert haben und was auf was sie auch für gesellschaftliche Folgen und so weiter hatten,
empfehle ich auch mal hier das Argument dagegen so etwas zu tun, auch wenn das natürlich.
Wie hieß das nochmal? Berufsverbot.
Na ja, die nennen es natürlich Gesinnungsprüfung. Ach so, du suchst den Podcast.
Mein der Podcast äh genau ja.
Ähm Dominik Domini.
Mit Rollout neunzehn Berufsverbote, Staatsschutzextremismus. Äh Dominik Riegold.
Wie heißt der? Ja, aber der Gast, der Gast, Dominik. Rigoal, ich habe, die wollte die ganze Zeit cool sagen. Dominik, Rigoy war da zu Gast und hat da äh drüber berichtet, der hat da lange Zugefund.
Ja, den habe ich glaube ich gehört, das war sehr informativ.
Ne, den kann man kann man hier an der Stelle mal empfehlen. Podcast sollen wir auch immer empfehlen. Ähm warum das so eine schlechte Idee ist? Was nämlich passieren wird? Ähm,
Rechtspopulisten und Antisemiten können das natürlich dann auch als Einladung missverstehen,
da zu denunzieren, ja? Und dann sagst du irgendwie, dann arbeitest du irgendwie in Ruhe, irgendwie sag mal, in Oberschöneweide, in der in der Beratungsstelle ähm,
die sich irgendwie, die im Prinzip,
versucht da, ne, für Demokratie und so weiter zu arbeiten und dann hetzen die irgendwie dann da den mehr oder weniger den Staatsschutz auf dich und der prüft dann äh
Ob du nicht vielleicht doch feine Sahne Fischfilet hörst, ja? Solche es ist so äh ist natürlich alles nicht nicht so, wie man das haben möchte und deswegen ist das eine sehr,
eine eine nicht so gute Idee.
Ähm fällt mir ein, da gab's glaube ich auch mal einen Podcast von Petro Laut. Vitolo zehn Nazis in Schöneweide. Wurde.
So ein Zufall auch.
So
Ja, da gab's also die Anhörung, wir werden sehen, wie äh ob man sich das in Hessen nochmal anders überlegt. Ähm da waren aber jetzt mal wieder alle vertreten, also Chaos, Computerclub, insbesondere eben Chaos Darmstadt,
Ähm Forum für äh man Pfiff, ich vergesse immer Forum der Informatikerin für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Ähm.
Gesellschaft für Informatik und so weiter, immerhin wurde da gut geladen in in Hessen, aber äh werden sehen, äh ob was man sich dazu hat sagen lassen.
Ja Tim, ich habe letztens übrigens ähm.
Porno von mir gesehen.
Krassen Porno von dir gesehen.
Ja, alles alles fake.
Na ja, das sah aber ganz schön echt aus.
Deep Fakes nach Deep Learning jetzt kommt auch noch das womit schon irgendwie immer zu rechnen war, nämlich das,
wir leider auch den Bildern nicht mehr glauben dürfen und das ist leider doof.
Also was steckt dahinter? Es gibt eine.
Also jemand hat eine App geschrieben.
Software geschrieben. Wie er nennt die sich Fake App,
und die benutzt halt so jetzt die seit ein, zwei Jahren relativ gängigen Algorithmen, das Machine Learning,
die ja schon extreme Fortschritte gemacht hat beim,
applizieren, von so erlernten Massenwissen, das heißt, man hat halt viele Daten, zum Beispiel, viele Fotos, wo man irgendwelche Dinge drauf erkennen kann, wenn man das halt oft genug durch dieses Raster
durchschmeißt, dann bilden sich dahinter Datenstrukturen aus, die man in den Algorithmus werfen kann und damit kriegt man dann irgendwie alles
erkannt und damit auch analysiert, sprich diese Software analysiert Fotos,
Gesichter und ist in der Lage, diese Gesichter auf andere Gesichter draufzukleben und wenn man dann halt entsprechendes Pornomaterial mal nimmt, dann kann er halt schnell mal ein
Ja, auf den ersten Blick extrem kompromittierendes Dokument bei herauskommen.
Also die Idee, wie das äh also es braucht sehr viel oder es braucht viele Bilder von einer Person,
und baut dann offenbar so ein 3D Modell, würde ich jetzt mal so schätzen von dem Gesicht und quasi versucht aus dem einen Bild oder aus seinem Datenmodell,
zu prognostizieren, wie das Gesicht in einem anderen Bild aussieht. Ja, so dass du halt hast ganz viele Bilder und irgendwie.
An der Belichtungssituation.
An der Überlegungssituation und dann äh hast du irgendwann im Zweifelsfall,
lernt dein dein Team Learning Algorithmus wie dieses Gesicht sich dreidimensional,
stellt und wie das in einer bestimmten Position auszusehen hat und ob's lacht oder weint. Im Prinzip kann's ja quasi jedes einzelne Bild, was du da rein fütterst, wieder zur Vorhersage nehmen, sagen, aha, ich brauche also ein,
meine die Idealösung ist also etwas, wo ich jeweils dieses Bild, was ich gerade dazu bekommen habe, so genau wie möglich vorhersage, aus dem Rest der Bilder,
Und das ist jetzt äh so gut, dass es offenbar sogar auch in Videos funktioniert.
Und ich habe bis jetzt nur Videos gesehen, wo überall,
Nikolas Cage dann drin auftauchte als Hommage an den Film. Äh Face of also neunziger Jahre Film, oder?
Ich kann mich da gar nicht. Ich kann mich nur noch grob dran erinnern. Aber da haben die doch irgendwie auch so eine Gesichtstransplantation oder sowas gemacht, ne? Und deswegen äh die quasi diese die Teile, die nicht gelöscht werden, da ist die ganze Zeit Nikolas Cage und liest die Nachrichten vor und ist Präsident und
Ähm.
Körper des Feindes hieß er hier.
Im Kömper meines Vereines, genau und dann ist er Präsident und dann ist er der. So ja.
Das halten wir davon.
Das Problem, was ich daran sehe, ist.
Weniger oder also ja, also das mit diesen Pornos herkommen, okay, er ist jetzt einfach stoßner. Also kompromittierendes äh also irgendwie du wirst im Zweifelsfall,
Also dass wir diesen Pornos ja gut, das ist jetzt nicht unser Hauptproblem. Ähm das Problem ist natürlich auch, dass du sehr konkret.
Muss ja nicht, es muss ja nicht immer ein Porno sein. Könntest dich ja auch einfach irgendwo hinsetzen und sagen, okay, du verlierst jetzt irgendwie die Kriegserklärung an Nordkorea.
Ja, da reicht ja auch ein Jahr, da war ein Banküberfall und wir haben hier ein Video, wie sie da drei Stunden von dieser Bank rumgelungert haben.
Aus unseren Überwachungskameras in HD. Sag mal, äußern sie sich doch mal dazu. Ja, äh das war ich nicht. Ja, aber das sind doch sie. Schauen sie doch mal.
Und das ist genau das andere Problem, wird das öfter, also welches Problem werden wir öfter haben? Das Problem, dass ein Fake-Video irgendwo auftaucht.
Oder das Problem, dass dass ein echtes Video bestritten wird.
Was glaubst du, wenn wir in in der heutigen Zeit öfter haben? Also beides, beides ist, beides ist ein Problem, ne. Wie gesagt, Kriegserklärung an Nordkorea oder so.
Das ist eine reine mathematische Logik natürlich für mehr, mehr Filme auftauchen als bestritten werden, weil es können nicht mehr bestritten werden als äh auftauchen.
Nee, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ach also äh.
Äh
Klar, es werden mehr, nee, es könnte ja sein, dass wir mehr.
Also du sagst, du sagst, okay, die Zahl, die von Filmen, die bestritten wird, wird öfter sein. Klar, ja, genau, weil man wahrschein.
Nein, ich meine es hängt jetzt davon ab, was zählst du jetzt, ja? Zählst du jeden Film, der mit Deepfake äh als Deep Fake gemacht wird? Oder zählst du wie oft äh sich jemand darüber aufregt.
Anderes andersrum. Je jeder Film über den gesagt wird, es ist ein Diebfake.
Wird der wahrscheinliche Original sein oder wird er wahrscheinlicher ein Diebfake sein.
So, dass es quasi die die also jedes Mal, wenn einer sagt, äh das ist ein Deep-Fake, ja?
Haben wir dann öfter die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es tatsächlich ein Deepfake ist und die Person,
sich zu Recht dagegen wehrt? Oder haben wir öfter diese, die dahinter liegende Situation, dass es kein Dead-Fake ist, aber die Leute sagen,
Ist mir doch egal, in der schlechten Qualität, wie ich vor zehn Jahren dabei gefilmt wurde, wie ich hier in in vertrauter Runde äh eine Line Cooks äh ziehe. Ähm das ist doch ein ganz offensichtlichen Diebfeg. Ich komme mit der Nummer raus. Meine ähm.
Mein Ruf wird dadurch nicht kompromittiert.
Ja, keine Ahnung, was häufiger auftritt, aber man könnte vielleicht einfach mal schauen.
Und ich glaube, beides ist halt das Problem.
Ja, also es sind, es sind jetzt zwei interessante Szenarien, aber man sollte sich vielleicht über die Szenarien mal schon nochmal ein paar Gedanken machen und jetzt gleich zu distopisch äh rüberzukommen
Ich denke mir halt gerade erstmal so im ersten Moment, okay, was wer hat jetzt ein das größte Interesse, solches Material überhaupt zu produzieren
Da haben wir dann auf der einen Seite ähm so ganz klassische ähm,
Sag mal so Paparazzi gestützte äh sogenannte Journalismus, so Prominentenhunting et cetera, die ja immer äh geil drauf sind, dass da,
so, ne?
Tolle Fotos geschossen wurden von irgendeinem Urlaub, wo prominenter Arm mit prominenter B äh rumknutscht. Da muss man halt jetzt nicht mehr so einen Aufwand treiben, da baut man sich jetzt diese Filme einfach zusammen. Ich meine, da muss man sich nur
die die Cover von ich weiß leider nicht wie diese Postillen alle heißen, goldene Post oder was auch immer,
Ja, da blätterst du immer so drei Jahre zurück und stellst fest, dass also erstmal A sowieso fast alles irgendwie eine Montur ist mit äh doller Prinzessin, mit irgendwie ungeborenen Baby, was jetzt angeblich wirklich kommt und das wird dann so über die Jahre auch,
regelmäßig recycelt, also sie wiederholen ja sozusagen ihre Storys auch alle paar Monate, weil die Leute überhaupt eh nicht.
Weil die Leute nichts mehr mehr.
Weil die Leute nichts mehr merken beziehungsweise weil weil's auch überhaupt nicht wichtig ist, ob jetzt irgendwas stimmt oder nicht. Das finde ich auch so beunruhigend, ne? Das an der Stelle auch schon so dieses,
Wenn du darauf hinweist, ja, hier, das ist wahrscheinlich alles irgendwie die ganze Zeit fake, dann kommen dann halt so Antworten wie,
Ja, aber man kann ja sowieso nichts mehr was,
glauben, dann ist das ja auch egal, aber mich unterhält es zumindest in diesem Moment. Das ist eigentlich so der Abrieb, den ich am meisten stört, dass es den Leuten das auch noch wirklich egal ist,
Es sei denn, es regt sich halt mal wirklich was auf, dann stimmt's natürlich.
Und das ist dann eben schon diese nächste Eskalationsebene, dass natürlich hier.
Abgesehen so von den offensichtlichen Dingern, mit denen auch heute schon Geld gemacht wird und wo solche Deepfakes dann ganz hilfreich sein können. Das wäre natürlich vor allem auf Social Media,
dieses ganze Cup-Barack Obama hat gesagt sowieso und hier ist The Proof Video, ne?
Wir sind ja schon wie viele Fotos heutzutage schon zusammen geschustert werden, falsch zitiert werden
et cetera, äh, wo einfach Dinge halt einfach behauptet werden, die schlicht nicht wahr sind, das ist ja bei unseren Freunden im rechten Lager, ähm, besonders beliebt
In der politischen Auseinandersetzung und das wird sicherlich,
sehr schnell angereichert werden, um dieses sogenannte Originalvideomaterial. Und du wirst sehr viel mehr damit zu tun haben, darauf hinzuweisen, dass das mal wieder alles im Einzelnen nicht stimmt und zu dem Zeitpunkt ist so ein Video halt auch schon dreißigtausend Mal geklickt,
die Leute, die das lesen und sich damit ihrer Position bestärken und andere schwache Seelen mit äh in ihr Boot ziehen,
Die nehmen natürlich an diesem ganzen die Banking Informationsstrudel überhaupt nicht teil und deswegen wird sich das, was wir heute schon sehen, noch weiter vertiefen.
Das heißt aber auch da meine ich wie gesagt es gibt noch den umgekehrten Fehler, den wir, den die Öffentlichkeit machen kann.
Was als Fake zu halten, was halt gar keins ist.
Ja und da das glaube ich, ich würde tatsächlich in der heutigen Zeit das die Gefahr noch größer einschätzen, ja? Das,
Dinge, die echt sind als fake bezeichnet werden.
Klar. Dinge, die nicht.
Als das Dinge, die nicht echt sind.
Nennenswert Leute überzeugen. Und wenn und wenn beide Fehler.
Nicht mehr unterscheidbar sind, weil immer alle leugnen werden, dass etwas stimmt und das, was bisher mit das,
Für uns gesellschaftlich.
Vertrauenswürdigste Beweisstück war, nämlich eine Aufzeichnung. Ja, doch das hast du getan, hier Video, ne? Ähm wenn das wegfällt.
Dann ja, dann fällt immer mehr.
Des Konzeptes einer Wahrheit weg,
und das ist sehr ärgerlich, denn so sehr die Wahrheit immer im Auge des Betrachters liegt, gibt es nun einmal da draußen.
Objektive Fakten und Nichtfakten. Und bisher war ein Video in der Regel,
überzeugend,
oder konnte ein Video überzeugend sein, dass es sich dabei um einen Fakt handelt, dass das geschehen ist. Andererseits gibt es seit langer Zeit,
irgendwelche drei D Effekte und sonst was, die uns auch davon überzeugen, dass Luke Skywalker.
Darf ich jetzt nicht sagen, weil es wäre sonst ein Spoiler, aber ähm die uns davon überzeugen, dass diese Dinge geschehen seien,
Und das hat jetzt noch nicht zum Untergang der Zivilisation geführt,
obwohl man sich auch heute mit sehr moderatem Aufwand zum Beispiel hinsetzen kann und eine Mondlandung fälscht. Wusstest du eigentlich Tim, dass die Mondlandung gefälscht ist?
Nee, wusste ich nicht.
Also ne, um mal um das mal wieder in in etwas in etwas anderen Rahmen zu setzen, weil ich nicht weiß, ob's am Ende uns so dicke trifft.
Wie man jetzt davon, wie man befürchten könnte.
Ja, vielleicht wird es nicht so massiv ausfallen, aber wir werden das auf jeden Fall sehen. So und äh die also vor allem, also jetzt habe ich nochmal ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht, so was wird am meisten auftreten. Ich denke tatsächlich, dass dieses,
Die Behauptung, dass was nicht stimmt, das werden wir am häufigsten sehen.
Das auf jeden Fall. Weil die werden wir sehen, ob's stimmt oder nicht. Aber wird diese behaupt, wird diese Behauptung öfter wahr oder öfter falsch sein.
Sie wird oft sehr falsch sein.
Ja. Und das ist das ist das, was mir eigentlich am meisten Sorgen macht.
Zurecht. Ja ja, ach endlich mal wieder richtig schlechte Nachrichten nicht, oder? Geil.
Wir haben noch eine schlechtere.
Wirklich Sendung ist zu Ende.
Nein, nicht. Nee, äh John Parry Balow ist gestorben.
Ja, das ist recht früh sogar, siebzig ist er geworden.
Wer hat denn noch länger geschafft als ich so in den letzten Jahren geglaubt habe, dass er es noch schafft so? War äh sehr krank.
Ja, genau, er war schon länger krank, ich weiß nicht genau, worunter er gelitten hat, aber es war ihm auch anzusehen, also sehr äh Verfallen, so in den letz
äh vor vierzehn Jahren. Er war ja noch vor einigen Jahren auf dem Kongress und war ja auch Keynote-Speaker auf dem Kongress und ich weiß natürlich jetzt gerade nicht mehr genau auf welchem, aber ich werde es sofort nachschlagen.
Aber mindestens zehn Jahre her.
Das ist schon ein bisschen her, das war auf jeden Fall noch in Berlin.
Und das war Hooken U Trust äh zweitausendsechs.
Jahre her, dreiundzwanzigster Chaos Konikirschen Kongress.
Das war eine sehr launige Ansprache. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, es war ein bisschen.
Das war ganz interessant. Also er hat eigentlich so äh zu Hackern gesprochen, aber er hatte halt mehr so,
Die Hackalmen sind die er so kannte. Also es war immer so dieses amerikanische und unterstellte dann halt so in seiner Ansprache auch so ein bisschen allen so latent so ja lasst euch mal nicht zu sehr auf Geheimdienste ein et cetera et cetera,
Richtig Gegenwind bekam, schon in den Nachfragen war ganz interessant, sich das auch nochmal anzuschauen. Ähm und dann.
Doch sehr nachhaltig äh auch in Nachgesprächen,
Nochmal den Unterschied erklärt bekommen hat, den wir zumindest so in der europäischen und speziell der deutschen Hacker äh Kultur sehen im Vergleich zur amerikanischen dreiundzwanzig C drei. Das war auch,
So einer der ersten Kongresse, die auch diesen amerikanischen Outreach, den wir damals gemacht haben, äh manifestiert haben. Also es ging um zweiundzwanzig C drei los. Dreiundzwanzig zu drei, das war schon so ein bisschen die Ankunft der ersten größeren
von, also es war schon immer Amerikaner da, aber es gab einen expliziten Wunsch,
ähm des Clubs und des der Kongressorga, dass auch wirklich ähm mal gezielt anzustreben und äh viele Leute wurden eingeladen und,
auch die Einladung von Balu, et cetera, da stand alles so ein bisschen in diesem,
Kontext. Na ja und dann merkte man halt auch ganz gut an seiner Rede, wo da so die Disfonanz in der in der Wahrnehmung ist und so. Und von daher fand ich das ganz interessant, aber es war für ihn, glaube ich, auch sehr lehrreich, weil,
danach das Thema kocht ja dann den ganzen Tag und es wurde irgendwie auf ihn eingeredet und.
Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, weil das nicht alle äh vielleicht so Unterschiede so genau kennen, wie wir. Ähm,
Was du meinst, wofür er Gegenwind bekommen hat, ist,
dass in der deutschen Hackerszene die Idee wir kooperieren jetzt mit den Geheimdiensten bei weitem,
nicht zu vertreten ist, wie sie es traditionell in der US-amerikanischen Szene ist. Ähm die US-Hacker-Szene äh ist,
Davon finanziert und es füllt die Leute mit Stolz
Security Clearences zu haben und für dieses oder jene Regierungsnahe Organisation oder Zulieferer oder Department oder sonstiges zu wirken
für die NATO zu arbeiten und dass es für die US Security Industrie auch tatsächlich ein einfach der einzige Markt,
der sich da nennenswert bietet. Klar, du kannst natürlich noch irgendwie bei einem der zivilen ähm.
Ja, weiß, wie soll man sie nennen? Bei einem der zivilen Eroberer arbeiten, also bei Facebook oder Kugel, ja. Die äh ohne Waffen die Welt erobern. Aber ähm.
Eigentlich gerade so diese Security Szene, die da auch sehr
also sehr machomäßig und äh Frauenverachten gerne mal auf der auf der Blacked oder so unterwegs ist. Ähm da ist die deutsche Hackerszene dann doch relativ weit von innen entfernt in der
ja doch sehr geheimdienstkritischen Ausrichtung,
die, die deutsche Hackerszene da über Jahrzehnte kultiviert,
Soll nicht heißen, dass die deutsche Hacker-Szene alles nur, also quasi in deren Augen ist.
Tollen sind, aber wir haben halt einen anderen.
Da gibt's einen Groß, da gibt's einen großen Unterschied, insbesondere eben in den in so politischen Fragen.
Ja, aber äh wir wollten ja eigentlich über John Paribalo reden, warum ist er jetzt hier überhaupt erwähnt? Er ist halt
bekannt geworden, dadurch, dass er eigentlich als,
elektronischer Bürgerrechtler und Mitbegründer der Elektronik Front hier Foundation äh Welle gemacht hat
wird auch immer gerne wieder nachgetragen, dass er ja früher so Songtexter von der Rockband Red Full Dead äh gewesen ist. Also ein eine illustre Type, der so in dieser aufgeklärten amerikanischen ähm
Szene unterwegs war damals und ja und dann hat er besondere Aufmerksamkeit mal dadurch bekommen, dass er irgendwie neunzehnhundertsechsundneunzig
Rednerpult, äh des Weltwirtschaftsforums in Da wo's äh einfach mal die Unabhängigkeit des Cyberspace ausruft, was damals den Zeitgeist sehr gut getroffen hat.
Regierungen der industriellen Welt. Ihr müden Giganten aus Fleisch, Fleisch und Stahl. Ich,
Komme aus dem Cyberspace,
der neuen Heimat des Geistes. Im Namen der Zukunft bitte ich euch Vertreter einer vergangenen Zeit. Lasst uns in Ruhe,
ihr seid bei uns nicht willkommen, wo wir uns versammeln, besitzt ihr keine Macht mehr.
Wir besitzen keine gewählte Regierung und wir wohl werden wohl auch nie eine bekommen. Und so wende ich mich mit keiner größeren Autorität an euch als der,
mit der die Freiheit selber spricht,
Ich erkläre den globalen sozialen Raum, den wir errichten, als gänzlich unabhängig von der Tyrannei, die ihr über uns auszuüben anstrebt,
ihr habt hier kein moralisches Recht zu regieren. Noch besitzt ihr Methoden, es zu erzwingen, die wir zu befürchten hätten,
Und es geht dann noch längere Zeit so weiter.
Ja er war selber etwas überrascht über die Rückmeldung auf seinen Text und er meinte, er hätte auch glaube ich nicht äh sehr gut nachgedacht. Das ist wohl so etwas, was er sehr im Affekt äh entstanden ist.
Er sagte dazu ähm zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt, also er wurde auch von übrigens in der LMP einhundertzweiundsiebzig, wo die unabhängig Unabhängigkeitserklärung des Cyberspace nämlich dann ihren dreißigsten Geburtstag hatte,
wo wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen haben. Haben wir auch gesagt, naja, so ein bisschen äh blauäugig, ne, weil ähm,
Im Prinzip der häufigste Kritikpunkt an diesem Text war, na ja, pass auf, wo du den Start gänzlich rausscheust, übernimmt halt der Kapitalismus,
Und ähm damit das Recht des Stärkeren und äh damit war noch nie jemandem geholfen,
Und dazu sagte äh John Perry Balau später dann.
Ähm ich wusste, dass es ein guter, eine guter ein guter Weg die Zukunft zu erfinden ist,
sie vorherzusagen. Also habe ich Utopia vorhergesagt.
Um eine äh Freiheit, um einen guten äh Headstart, also einem guten, einem guten um der Freiheit, einen guten Vorsprung zu verschaffen,
Ähm bevor dann äh die Gesetze von Moor und Mettkauf darin endeten, ähm was,
Edward Snowden jetzt korrekt den Turnkey Total ihrer Totalitarismus nennt. Also er sagt ja der hat bewusst äh den Patos der Freiheit äh und der Widerstandskraft hier gesetzt,
um äh um die Bürgerrechtsbewegung äh im Internet und in den Netzen so stark zu machen äh wie sie dann auch in der mit der IFF dann doch,
In den USA auch wurde. Die IFF äh HS eine enorm einflussreiche Organisation geworden und die äh zu mobilisieren weiß, wie wenige andere.
Und ähm das eben jetzt seit vielen Jahrzehnten im Geiste von äh John Perry Balo.
Auch tut und auch hierzulande ein großes äh Vorbild ist, ja? Also ähm digitale Gesellschaft wollte die IFF werden,
eine weitere Bürgerrechtsorganisation in Deutschland einfach der IFF sehr nach und hat auch nur,
ein Buchstaben im Alphabet um zwei inkrementiert. Ähm insofern das Vorbild, was IFF da geschaffen hat und auch diesen Geist, den äh John Pary Balo da äh geschaffen hat. Ich glaube, der lebt ähm.
Äh der lebt sehr viel weiter und das, ich glaube, dass das, was er da sagt, dass das durchaus stimmt, dass diese Unabhängigkeitserklärung eben vielen Leuten nicht vollständig ausgetrieben wurde und das.
Trotz, also das halt schon relativ klar ist so. Ähm das ist erstmal unser Internet,
Und dann können wir gucken, was da, was wir da drin machen wollen,
Dummerweise ist es eben eine rein libertäre Idee und wir sehen eben, wenn das ja, dass dann eben äh Facebook kommt und sagt so, ja, hier, ich habe auch ein Internet, kommt doch da rein und alle sagen so, yeah.
Ja, es ist der, der gute alte, also ich meine, wenn er von wir spricht, ne, dann ist halt die Frage, wer ist gemeint und damals war halt gemeint,
Na ja, so der der Urkern, der Urschleim des Internets, der so die ersten zehn Jahre geprägt hat und der ja vom Global Village geträumt hat und da teilweise auch noch rumsitzt
während halt Facebook sozusagen das das Global Soho geworden ist, wo wir alle äh sich treffen und Party machen und ähm.
Jetzt gibt's nicht nur ein Dorf, jetzt gibt's da eine,
größeren komplexen urbanen Raum, das Global Village selber ist ein bisschen angewachsen, aber halt nicht so sehr wie der Rest. Ja und deswegen haben wir es jetzt mit diesen mega Citys zu tun,
die nicht ganz so einfach zu kontrollieren sind. Na ja gut.
Aber das äh übrigens dieser dieser Ursprung der IFF, der der findet sich ja nämlich auch in dem in dem Gründungstext der IFF wieder,
Ähm wo er genau diesen diese Trennung beschreibt und sagt so, es gibt hier einige, die haben schon gesehen,
Die wissen, die haben das Licht gesehen, die wissen, was hier äh und so weiter und es gibt den Rest der Gesellschaft und der Rest dieser Gesellschaft, der muss jetzt auch endlich über diese Elektronikfront hier. Und wir gehen,
Also die elektronische Grenze, die gesamte Gesellschaft muss die elektronische Grenze überwinden, die uns als Pioniere gerade noch von den nicht sehenden Trend so äh übertreu. Er hat ja,
durchaus so ein bisschen paar, dass da ja dieser dann doch etwas ähm.
Ähm da hat Rocksongs geschrieben, also da muss man schon vom Leder ziehen. Sonst kommt das nicht so an. Aber das ist hier, da ist man sicherlich nicht schlecht beraten, wenn man sich daran orientiert.
Eine eine ja doch sehr prägende Person, die ähm sich gar nicht so oft zu Wort gemeldet hat, aber wenn dann richtig,
Und mit der Gründung der IFF eben da doch durchaus eben sehr viel äh Geschichte geprägt hat.
So alt ist das Internet jetzt schon, das war schon die jungen Hiron irgendwie alle als alte Leute äh dahinter müssen. Da werden wir jetzt sicherlich demnächst noch mehr Abgänge äh zu verzeichnen haben, aber
die Wahrnehmung, dass das alles mal so nur so junge Kekse sind, die ist jetzt auch langsam vorbei,
Naja, tschüss. Schon peribalos bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung.
Ja. Haben wir noch irgendeinen Witz zum Ende?
Nee, ist jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt haben wir schon.
Ist nicht mehr witzig jetzt, ne.
Halt aus mit Karneval nächste Woche wieder,
Ich bin mir sicher, die äh Koalition, welche auch immer da jetzt zusammenkommt, wird uns noch genug genug liefern, um auch weiterhin ähm Spitzbühmischweiksen äh.
Tja.
Weiterleben zu lassen.
Ja euch bitte auch.
Genau. Noch frohe, rote Nasen und äh du wolltest dich noch bedanken.
Ja, ich danke Markus, Andreas, Michael und Paul.
Und ich bedanke mich auch und äh tschüss bis nächste Woche.
Ciao ciao.